it is getting too loud apparently for
the White House to ignore the house
speaker is warning the Biden border
crisis is far past its Breaking Point
lawmakers witnessing illegal immigrants
Crossing into the country flowing in as
they visited Eagle Pass Texas some of us
myself included have been saying this
for two years house Speaker Johnson
leading the largest border delegation to
date more than 60 all republ Republicans
getting an up close look at the border
crisis Johnson and his fellow
Republicans tore into the Biden
Administration under President Biden
America has laid out a welcome M to
illegal immigrants Smugglers and cartels
he is responsible for the grave threat
to our national security the American
people are absolutely sick of the
policies that they've seen now is the
time to to make sure America is safe and
we do that by taking a down payment on
border security in 24 last month record
month 300,000 illegal migrants come into
the country the pace of the Biden
Administration in his in his term as
president will will reach 12 million
when they're done the policies of May
orcus are being used by the cartels to
exploit the American people and make
billions of dollars accountability is
coming I
promise well there it is House
Republicans vowing accountability for
Homeland secretary Alejandro
moorus they plan to hold their first
impeachment hearing now that date has
been
set and are looking into impeaching him
by next week my orcus and the White
House have dismissed this tital wave of
criticism doing this intentionally and
that you're a liar your
reaction I don't have time um for Words
uh like that we are focused here on
Solutions the president has confidence
in the secretary what they're doing the
House Republicans are doing uh with this
imp impeachment incy is baseless uh we
believe that uh it's a political stunt
we have House Republicans that's
literally blocking the president's
effort to do something that's what
they're doing they're playing political
games can't even believe she says that
with a straight face in Focus
Congressman Andy bigs Republican of
Arizona and co-chair of the border
security caucus and yes he was there
yesterday with that very large group of
Republicans we'll get to him in a moment
let's begin with Bill maluan in Eagle
Pass Texas
Bill Harris good morning to you when
those Republicans were here in Eagle
Pass yesterday they said they got a
briefing from border patrol and we're
told that the cartel across the river
from us is making $32 million per week
just here in the Eagle Pass area based
off their human smuggling which is going
on all along the southern border take a
look at this video our team shot in
Arizona late yesterday afternoon this is
that lukeville area we've been reporting
from the last few weeks more men from
all around the world Crossing illegally
large numbers of men from Africa
countries like Liberia Mali senagal
Guinea others Crossing later in the day
more of a mixture of family units some
women from Ecuador Brazil some of those
other countries but we also encountered
a man from Guinea who was on the other
side of the border wall and was just
begging border patrol to please let him
into the US he also for some reason had
a New York state ID card in his hand
take a listen to this
exchange please please please my brother
please don't let me here please may
Allah help
you so you see it there that's that New
York state ID card he's holding in his
hand there we don't know much about it
if it's his or somebody else's if it's
real or fake how he has it why he has it
uh all we know is that man did later
successfully crossed illegally into the
lukeville area uh our border patrol
contacts telling us that but he was one
of several men waiting near a breach in
the border wall you can see the the cut
in the beam right there who were hoping
to be able to go through that open
breach and back out here live look
Republicans have been talking for a long
time about the threat of impeaching
secretary my orcus well next week as you
mentioned earlier in your show Harris uh
they're going to have their very first
official impeachment inquiry hearing
that is going to be set for January 10th
that is going to be the first step
towards a potential markup and
eventually maybe a house floor vote in
terms of finally impeaching secretary my
orcus we'll see how it all plays out
we'll send it back to you Bill maluan
thank you very much very startling to
hear that man begged to be let in and
then of course he just came on in on his
own illegally I mean you wonder how many
times a minute that's happening thank
you in Focus now Republican Congressman
Andy bigs of Arizona co-chair of the
border security caucus member of of the
house Judiciary and oversight committees
and Congressman bigs again was with h a
large uh group of Republicans at the
border I know you went previously on
another delegation what can you tell me
about what's happening there and why the
president now has his eyes on all of
you well so what's happening on the
border is it's worse than it's ever been
uh Harris as you know more than
300,000 uh encounters last month but
that doesn't include the Goda aways and
known Goda aways so it's worse than ever
and um over the last two days I I took a
separate group um the day before so we
could get a separate view uh what I call
a non-s sanitized view non- regime non
Biden Administration View and it is so
bad um and the people we talk to we talk
to health administrators we talk to
First Responders we talked to the local
ranchers and business people
um and we talked I talked to the Texas
borders are so we were there and I will
tell you that it it continues to get
worse and we are actually
facilitating this Administration is
facilitating facilitating the logistic
arms of transporting people uh from the
the cartels importing into the United
States or exporting to the United States
we are facilitating that and we met
actually met with the Inspector General
for the DHS last night and and more than
75% his audit showed more than 75% of
these people Harris of the 8 million or
so that have come in under Joe Biden we
have no idea where they are they are
totally unaccountable to any us
Authority that that is a huge number so
what you're saying is as they come here
into the and I'm in New York so you know
it's a sanctuary City here but as they
come in and they try to get to other
places you're saying as they fan out
even once they've come illegally we have
no idea where they are and so that
gotway number may be those that we
didn't identify but they're all getting
away yeah that's that's right at least
75% of
them yeah 75% but most of the people
that come in they we have to take them
on their word because there is no way to
vet them so so come here and commit a
crime against this nation by entering
illegally why in the world would we take
them at their word those who choose not
to go through the
checkpoints no I'm I'm with you 100% And
and this Administration uh won't let do
even for instance DNA uh testing of of
uh people under the age of 14
why just think of the human trafficking
child trafficking that we've seen think
of the uh special benefits that we give
to uh these family units we have
concocted madeup family units coming
coming in and we want to do the DNA
testing to see oh are they you related
to them and then we're going to release
them they instead of stopping them at
the border Harris or or uh turning them
away uh this Administration has said
we're going to not only facilitate their
entry we're going to facilitate their
distribution throughout the United
States and we're not going to keep track
of them look I I'm sure you're seeing
the numbers uh just eye popping numbers
of how much money the cartels are making
by the day by the individual uh it we we
are now just almost like the agents for
the
cartel that's right no you're exactly
right that's what I mean when I say the
logistical arm they come in when I was
in lukeville two weeks ago we we saw
people just like Bill was showing you in
his report in fact bill was down there
with me but we you asked them where are
you going because we would ask as many
people as we could where are you going
and they would pull out a laminated
haris a laminated card with phone
numbers and addresses throughout the
country this is well organized this is
not happen stance this is by Design yeah
uh President Biden's justice department
is suing as you know the state of Texas
over its new border security law and the
bill would allow State authorities to
arrest certain illegal immigrants and
potentially give state judges the power
to deport them the lawsuit comes the
very same week the doj filed for the US
Supreme Court to intervene over the
state use of razor wire to prot protect
its border you know to keep the people
illegally from just flowing into Texas
former acting ice director Tom Homan
with
this I think in the end Texas will lose
a lawsuit and that's it's a shame
because Texas is simply trying to
protect their state and their residence
and the federal government has advocated
their responsibility they are not doing
anything to secure the Border just real
rapid fire first of all he said there he
thinks that Texas is going to lose this
lawsuit do you think that
I think they have a chance to win it's
an uphill climb but he the point he made
is the is the legal Point has the
federal government vacated the field in
this area and I think they vacated it a
long time ago that gives them an
opportunity to use article 4 section 4
protection for the state ah okay of
course it would nobody's really talking
about that very much though and when you
say vacating their responsibility you
and I have seen this for years now it's
not breaking news all right I said Rapid
Fire Let's quickly get to this next
thing is my orcus just the figurehead
like how how do you really get to the
heart of this do you impeach the guy
whose face is on Biden's border crisis
or can you go
deeper well you have to start with
mayorcas he is not just a figurehead
these policies he has concocted he has
enforced them these policies and he has
refusing to actually enforce the laws of
title 8 which would give us some relief
along the border I think he's uh he's
certainly uh abdicated his
responsibility and Duty he should be
impeached Congressman bigs thank you I I
can hear the level of frustration in
your voice we talk enough I recognize
that this is really a critical point I
hope we get it right for America thank
you sir thank you Harris hey everyone
I'm Emily compano catch me and my
co-host Harris vulner and Kaye mcki on
outnumbered every weekday at 12: p.m.
Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights